So when learning like order of operations. That was something that I never
really thought twice of, especially you know when you're a kid and you're in
the math class and then you're in high school and college. And I mean you're
told that there's different order of operations but when you're programming
it's a little bit different because then you know you've got you know doubles
and ints and floats and that's something that like off the bat, like I kind of
struggled with, like sometimes my, like I would run my code and it would work,
other times it didn't work. And I ended up learning that one of the most
important things is being able to know the answer before it comes out and
understanding how that answer works. And understanding the sequence like the
operations like, what, what different things would work and what wouldn't work.
And, one of the things for me, like, you know, even just sitting down with a
piece of paper and understanding, okay, so if I divide by an int, will I get an
int back. Like, if it's a double that I was dividing by. Like, what, what's the
actual way to do this that's right. And then if that something wasn't right, I
really needed to work hard to understand why at first and now, I mean, it's
more instinctive that I like, I'll, I'll even write it not thinking twice about
it. But, when you're learning this, it's something that, like you don't realize
is actually important to keep things, I guess together and concise. Something
like that.